[Music]
high school football kicks off tonight
across the valley including at bishop
gorman high school that's where we have
kevin martin she's live with more on
tonight's matchup why the raiders are
also on hand hey
kevin oh hey guys yeah friday night
lights are back and i'll tell you what
it is a huge showdown here bishop gorman
two powerhouses going at it as they're
hosting st louis high school out of
hawaii and it's all about the raiders
that this is the showcase game tonight
and i'm joined by former raider james
harris james what does it mean to be
here today to represent the raiders and
be out in the community this is what
it's about the rate of supporting high
school football enjoying the friday
night for real lights and
i'm so happy to be here and i'm glad i
was being chosen to
put this on and man i'm having a good
time here i was going to come to the
game anyway but when the raiders asked
me to come i was more than happy to get
this done because this is the foundation
of football it's high school and if we
can get the kids
[Music]
squared away right here get to know the
fundamentals and the rules of the games
right here when they get to the pros
it'll be all much easier for them
exactly and you're a long time vegas
resident especially knowing that not
only are you here representing the
raiders but you know you're representing
the city and showing that giving back is
cool and fun to do yes giving back is
cool i've been here for about 10 years
man and i've been watching bits of
garment for a while and this is a great
program absolutely a great program but
the whole valley of
las vegas have some really good football
right now coming up and
by being a raider coming the raiders
coming here and us doing this with the
kids it makes it that much better
awesome who you got real quick you got
tonight you got st louis or bishop
gorman oh bishop gorman it's my home
team i love it awesome well thank you so
much james of course reporting live from
bishop gorman high school kevin martin
eight sports now